hey 42 here everyone's doing it we do it
on the couch in bed sometimes on our
mates house 18 to 29 year olds are most
likely to do it every day whilst the
older generation usually partakes less
than once a month we do it way past our
bedtime and in some cases all night I
know I have I'm of course talking about
binge watching what were you thinking
although binge watching has technically
been a thing since DVD boxsets the term
didn't properly catch on an end to
vernacular speech until 2013 when
Netflix had the genius idea of releasing
every episode of a brand new series all
at once no longer did we have to stare
at our watches for a long grueling week
waiting for the next installment of our
favorite TV show to where it was all
land pensively awaiting are impatient
highs anytime we wanted and what did we
humans do with this newfound privilege
we do what we always do of course abused
it
why wait a week a day even an hour when
you could watch one episode straight
after the other in quick succession
before you know it your alarm is due to
go off in three hours time but you're
still considering just one more episode
the next morning you feel terrible
but let's be honest you're probably
going to do the same thing again that
very night as you stare at your sunken
dark eyes in the mirror you try to
reason with yourself sure you've lost a
bit of sleep but it's not that bad for
you right well I hate to break it to you
but watching that next episode might
just be the death of you and no I'm not
being dramatic a study carried out by
researchers at Osaka University in Japan
discovered the correlation between how
long you spend sitting in front of the
TV every day and how likely you are to
die of a pulmonary embolism
they found that people who regularly
watched more than five hours of TV a day
had a mortality rate two-and-a-half
times higher than those who watched just
two and a half hours per day less
netflix and chill' more net
and kill but it doesn't stop there
according to the Nurses Health Study for
every two hours women spend watching
television each day they have a 23%
higher risk of becoming obese and a 14%
greater chance of developing diabetes
and for those of you who have just left
out of your seats you may want to sit
back down for the next one researchers
from the university of queensland
australia constructed a model in which
they compared to life expectancy for
adults who watch TV compared to those
who didn't and the results were shocking
they found that for every hour you spend
glued to the screen you shorten your
life by 21.8 minutes to put that into
context if you spend six hours every
night binge watching the latest series
you can expect to live 4.8 years less
than someone who doesn't watch TV but
your life may not depend on just how you
watch but what you watch who and what we
interact with on a daily basis
drastically shapes who we are as a
person from our parents our friends our
daily activities interactions habits to
the food we put in our mouths all these
aspects of our lives make up who we are
for better or worse and that also
applies to the screens we stare at for
most of the day the media which fills
our minds could influence and define us
in ways we never thought possible in
this modern world you are what you watch
researchers in the 1970s conducted an
experiment to try and address the
effects of television and the programmes
we choose to give our attention to they
randomly assigned to groups of
low-income children aged 3 to 5 in the
first group the control group children
kept their TV viewing habits the same
and were allowed to watch what they
wanted in the second group the
experimental group the children were
given access to if they already liked it
Sesame Street and the parents were to
encourage their children to watch the
show once a month and the results
over a period of just six months the
group of children who were given access
to and encouraged to watch Sesame Street
gained 5.4 IQ points compared with the
control group and for those who watch to
show the most they experienced larger
gains in cognitive performance seem on
TV doesn't rot your brain but for every
year there is a young and although
watching one kind of TV program can
improve our lives watching another could
prove devastating especially for some in
March 2017 netflix released the first
series of 13 reasons why around the
world mental health services and
charities raised concern over the
graphic nature of the series who's from
saying it was glamourizing suicide which
could potentially lead to the tragic
phenomenon known as suicide contagion 13
reasons why which tells a tale of a
teenage girl who takes her own life was
in marketing terms a big hit Netflix is
notoriously shy at revealing their
viewership figures but the marketing
analytics firm jumpshots determined that
it was the second most viewed Netflix
season in the first 30 days after it
premiered its controversial subject
matter played a major role in its
success with an increase of 18% in
viewership from week one to week two the
fears of mental health advocates around
the world became all too real when it
was revealed that the release of 13
reasons why coincided with between
900,000 and 1.5 million more suicide
related Google searches in the USA there
was also a chilling 26% increase for the
search how to commit suicide there were
more tweets about this show in its first
week of being released than any other
Netflix show and during its surge in
popularity during the months of April
and May 2017 Stephen stack at Wayne
State University analyzed data which
showed that during that time the suicide
rate for boys aged between 10 and 19 in
the u.s. increased by 12 point 4 percent
and for girls there was a jump 21.7%
when compared with previous months but
wait 42 I enjoy been watching I find it
relaxing first of all I know you enjoy
it a 2013 Harris Interactive survey
conducted on behalf of Netflix found
that 73% of streamers have positive
feelings towards binge watching but
relaxing I'm not so sure you may feel
like you're distressing but in a study
conducted by the University of Toledo
where they analyze people's television
viewing habits they found that
respondents who identified as binge
Watchers reported higher levels of
stress anxiety and depression than
regular TV viewers so what's happening
why are we enjoying something so much
which is affecting our mental health you
wouldn't like to be bullied it's an
binned worthy rate so why are you so
willing and in fact yearning to
participate in something which is so
mentally harmful the answer might reside
in the reason why we receive so much
enjoyment in the first place let me ask
you a question during your last binge
session whether it be breaking band at
the office or Tiger King did you have
these sports running through your mind
just one more then I'll stop I only do
it on the weekends I need it to relax
everyone else does it if you have then
you might be disturbed to know that
these are the very same thoughts of an
addict yes you heard me right
you don't need needles poker chips or
alcohol to become an addict all you need
is a Netflix password and decent Wi-Fi
connection so what does Disney Plus and
heroin have in common
dopamine in simple terms dopamine is a
chemical released by the brain when you
have a positive reaction to something
that feeling after buying yourself
something new dopamine that friller
finding money on the pavement that's
dopamine your brain likes to take note
of what triggered these tasty little
dopamine hits and compels you to seek
out that same pleasure again
again this urge can be powerful and hard
to control so when you're enjoying the
latest new series your brain can't get
enough of this potent chemical and it
knows what it has to do to get more of
it make you watch just one more episode
think it's not a big deal
think again since 2019 people have been
seeking professional health to combat
their binge-watching addictions the
patient's admitted to not being able to
stop watching their favorite shows on
streaming platforms unable to control
themselves from watching more and more
Adam Cox a psychotherapist who has
treated these addicts says a TV
cliffhanger is a reward mechanism like
drink or drugs it releases dopamine and
that can be an issue for people you have
over stresses or anxieties in their life
it causes like of sleep which sends
productivity through the floor and stops
people forming proper relationships but
surely we the moderate
binge Watchers of this world are not
letting it affect our sleep that much
especially when according to a survey
published by the American Academy of
Sleep Medicine US adults ranked sleep as
a top priority second only to family
well apparently there's a caveat to that
88% of US adults have admitted that they
had lost sleep due to staying up late to
binge watch this percentage jumped to 95
percent
when looking at 18 to 44 year olds it
almost seems as if streaming platforms
are trying to make us lose sleep on
purpose and that theory might not be too
far-fetched
especially when the CEO of Netflix Reed
Hastings has publicly stated that sleep
is their competition so all of this
sounds pretty depressing and even though
you know it's bad for you you're
probably not going to stop considering
that binge watching is a generally
isolating activity if we don't spend our
nights staring at our dreamed
reflections on our laptop screens as the
credits roll what are we going to talk
about with our friends the next
they are work colleagues our families
strangers in the port watching the
latest new thing is our way of
participating in the public conversation
are not doing so could risk a serious
case of FOMO it might explain why in a
poll conducted by Radio Times comm 42%
of people surveyed admitted to
pretending they had seen a program when
they really haven't we're all guilty of
it so what can we do to carry on
watching our favorite shows and not risk
a possible disastrous outcome well
you'll be pleased to hear that although
not perfect there are some things you
can do to help combat the negative
consequences of binge watching and some
may even improve your viewing experience
first things first be mindful of what
you can say and I'm talking both in your
mouth and on the screen a study at the
University of Houston surveyed
undergraduate students on their viewing
and eating habits and made the
unsurprising discovery that the more
people watched television the more they
partook in unhealthy eating it's also
worth noting that according to a study
conducted by Cornell University what
genre you choose to watch affects how
much you eat comparing those who watched
action movies and talk shows viewers who
watched the action filled content ate
twice as much a similar outcome was
observed when analyzing those who
watched sub films versus those who chose
upbeat movies like romantic comedies the
participants who watched the tearjerkers
ate 55 percent more which explains why
my girlfriend eats me out of house and
home every time she puts on the notebook
mind you I also feel the need to comfort
eat after being subjected to two
grueling hours of Ryan Gosling not
shooting anyone swapping snacks for a
healthier alternative while settling in
for a TV marathon could make a huge
difference not only to your waistline
but to how long you live
drop the popcorn your life depends on it
and just like those kids watching Sesame
Street YouTube should be mindful of what
you're subjecting your mind to
watching something educational such as a
documentary interviews of inspiring and
successful people or men with mustaches
telling you interesting facts is a much
better use of your time than a
mind-numbing sitcom standing up once in
a while but do you any harm either
if you insist on watching the latest
series of stranger things back-to-back
dividing your binge-watching into chunks
could help prevent some of the negative
consequences that come from sitting on
your ass for hours on end
since most shows are either 22 or 44
minutes long remembering to take a break
after every episode could be a great
approach this is according to dr. Bonnie
rocket Wagner an expert on sedentary
behavior and diabetes prevention she
recommends stepping away from the screen
undoing anything do some push-ups go for
a short walk do some stretches doing
something is better than doing nothing
another shocking remedy to this binge
watching crisis might just be to not
binge watch at all hear me out
if you love TV shows and I mean really
love them watching them back-to-back is
doing yourself a disservice I like to
compare it to Christmas Christmas Day
December the 25th it's like a binge
watching marathon it's exciting filled
with new things and self-indulgence but
it's also intense filled with too much
food you feel worse at the end of it
than you did at the beginning and it
goes by way too quickly and before you
know it it's over and January begins but
when you think of Christmas it's not
usually the day itself which fills you
with that warm fuzzy feeling you cherish
so much it's to lead-up it's drinking
mulled wine by the fireplace wrapping
presents watching home alone for the
hundredth time and decorating the
Christmas tree watching an entire series
in one night is like having Christmas
without the anticipation leaving a day a
week perhaps in between episodes gives
you the time to fully appreciate all the
little things that you might otherwise
miss that precious time away from the
screen in between episodes is filled
with excitement curiosity
varies discussion anticipation gives you
time to fully absorb the characters the
plot the twists and turns which you
crave so much why deprive yourself of
that it's the journey not the
destination thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon because it
really helps me to continue to make
these videos the links in description
also you can get your hands on a first
edition signed copy of my new book
sticker flag in it by heading on over to
unbound publishing and pre-ordering
yours today the links in the description
thank you